While it's easily one of the most enjoyable
installments in the MCU, Avengers: Endgame
is anything but straightforward.
Filled with time travel, space aliens, doppelgangers
from the past, and a whole mess of magic space
rocks, there are plenty of moments in the
film that are simply confusing.
Fortunately, if there's any part of the movie
that makes you scratch your head, just wait
five minutes.
Chances are good someone involved in the production
will give an interview that attempts to straighten
it all out.
Case in point, sibling filmmakers Joe and
Anthony Russo got candid with Business Insider
about the Endgame scene featuring a past version
of the otherwise dead Norse God Loki.
While Iron Man, Ant-Man, Professor Hulk, and
Captain America return to New York City in
2012 to collect the Tesseract and Loki's scepter,
which held the Space Stone and the Mind Stone,
respectively, Loki swiftly grabs the Tesseract
and escapes Thor's custody through a portal.
Once he's gone, that's pretty much the last
anyone sees of Loki in Avengers: Endgame.
So, what went down?
Where is Loki now?
According to co-director Joe Russo, Loki is
still dead in the core Marvel Cinematic Universe
timeline; his capturing of the Space Stone
in 2012 doesn't reverse his Infinity War death
at the hands of Thanos.
But he is alive in a different pocket of the
multiverse.
Loki snatching the Stone and beaming away
created a unique timeline.
That more or less falls in line with the conversation
between Professor Hulk and the Ancient One,
when the two met to discuss him borrowing
the Time Stone.
Essentially, Loki's escape with the Space
Stone was significant enough to cause the
central timeline to break off into a branched
reality.
The filmmaker explained:
"Loki, when he teleports away with the [Space]
Stone, would create his own timeline.
It gets very complicated, but it would be
impossible for [Cap] to rectify the timeline
unless he found Loki.
The minute that Loki does something as dramatic
as take the Space Stone, he creates a branched
reality."
Now, Tony Stark and Steve Rogers did wind
up getting their hands on the Space Stone
by utilizing the last of their available Pym
Particles to travel to 1970, steal the Space
Stone from S.H.I.E.L.D., and then snag a few
more vials of Particles from Hank Pym's lab
so they could return home again.
This allowed them to fulfill their time heist
mission and load up their own Infinity Gauntlet
in the year 2023 to revive the heroes who
were killed at the end of Infinity War.
But that didn't fix the problem of there being
a Loki somewhere out there with the Space
Stone he stole in 2012.
The final moments of Endgame saw Cap returning
all six Infinity Stones to their rightful
places and times.
And in the case of the Space Stone, he took
that one back to the S.H.I.E.L.D. base in
1970, not to New York in 2012.
It's confusing, like Russo mentioned, but
the truth of the matter is that taking the
Tesseract from and returning it to 1970 doesn't
affect Loki snagging it in 2012, at least
not according to the time travel standards
by which Endgame operates.
"Somebody peed my pants."
"Time travel!"
As of now, past Loki is living it up with
the Space Stone in an alternate timeline.
He isn't the same character fans saw try to
kind of redeem himself in Thor: The Dark World.
He isn't the same one who fought Hela's army
in Thor: Ragnarok and then die in Avengers:
Infinity War, either.
This is pre-redemption arc Loki, a Loki who
is still a villain who tried to ravage Earth
on behalf of Thanos.
The door is open for this Loki to return to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in a future
film, but it's more likely that evil 2012
Loki will first rear his head on his standalone
streaming series headed to Disney+.
Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige has noted
that the Disney+ superhero series, which also
include WandaVision and a Winter Soldier/Falcon
team-up show, will, quote, "intersect with
the movies in a very big way," suggesting
that Loki's sneaky getaway in Endgame could
shape everything about his forthcoming TV
series.
It's unclear when the project will hit the
service, so fans have plenty of time to speculate
about how the series will explore Loki's alternate
timeline.
Is he being an all-out baddie and asking strangers
to bend the knee to him?
Or is he taking a more subtle approach to
villainy, kicking back while he chills his
butt on a throne somewhere?
Either seem plausible, and plot points we'd
be down to see unfold on the Loki series.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.